المواطنون يؤدون صلاه الجنازه على ثلاثه
شهداء من بين الشهداء الذين التقوا خلال
الساعات الماضيه في خانيونس
بعد
الصلاه سيتم نقلهم الى المقبره هنا في
داخل ساحه مستشفى
ناصر هنا ايضا شهيد
جديد احضر في هذه اللحظات على ما يبدو انه
استش متاثر
بجراحه الله
اكبر الان يتم
نقل الشهداء
الى هذه
الساحه وهي مساحه صغيره
جدا يتم تخصيصها من اجل دفن الشهداء هذه
مجزره هذه مجزره بكل ما في الكلم من معاني
هذا قتل عشوائي لا علاقه له لا بحماس ولا
بتنظيمات ولا باي شيء هذا قتل للشعب
الفلسطيني والان لا مجال للوصول الى
المقابر لان الدبابات الاسرائيليه اصلا
تحاصر المقابر وهي موجوده الان في المقابر
هنا الان اضطروا اهل اهل الشهداء ان شاء
الله اضطروا ان يدفنهم في داخل المستشفى ا
عمليه الدفن تجري في هذه
اللحظات
كما تشاهدون في الصوره
مشهد يتكرر تكرر في شمال قطاع غزه في
مدينه غزه وهنا يتكرر في في محافظه خان
يونس هذه هي الساحه التي اصبحت هنا مقبره
لدفن الشهداء الذين ارتقوا خلال عمليات
قصف قامت بها طائرات الاحتلال خلال الليله
الماضيه وفجر اليوم وحتى هذه اللحظه هناك
عملي القصف مستمره ساحه مستشفى ناصر اصبحت
مقبره
للشهداء كما تشاهدون في الصوره يعني اصبح
من الصعوبه بمكان وصول الاهالي وذو
الشهداء الى مقبره خان يونس في ظل تواجد
اليات
الاحتلال داخل
المقبره والتي وسعت من عملياتها
العسكريه في غرب محافظه خان يونس وتحت
غطاء كثيف من النيران سواء قصف من قبل
طائرات الاحتلال الحربيه وكذلك قصف مدفعي